thank you all for coming to listen to
this timely panel about the rise of
anti-Semitism um we thought it could
never happen
again that Jews are slaughtered in the
cruelest way cruelest way the had it
burned raped beaten up and yet we saw it
in Israel 2 weeks ago and we thought
that the resurging anti-Semitism in
Europe would never come to
America and yet we saw in the past two
weeks that it did come to America in
some ways even worse than in
Europe while students in Europe yell
free free Palestine and Israel genocide
and so on American students carry signs
with with paragliding murderers
glorifying them as
liberators also we heard University
professors in America expressed their
Joy about the atrocities committed by
Hamas and we saw Jewish students being
humiliated intimidated threatened
attacked on America's
campuses this is worse than what happens
today in
Europe I hear from my European friends
and for those who don't know I am
originally from Europe from Holland and
immigrated to the United States in 2006
I hear from my European friends that
Jews there are starting to pull their
children from public school and put them
in Jewish schools
instead and that some are removing their
mza the little scroll from their front
doorpost to hide their
Jewish the one and only Jewish newspaper
in Amsterdam is now delivered in a white
envelope this is worse than in
America yet I just heard the home of a
Jewish family was invaded around the
corner of our house in Studio City Los
Angeles and the home Invader threatened
the family yelling free Palestine and
kill the
Jews
what was much better in America you
won't believe it but it's true what was
much better in America than in Europe in
the past two weeks was the support for
Israel and the Jewish people among
others from the
media but also the military support of
course and public
opinion the personal support and
sympathy from our friends and
colleagues even CNN was better than the
media in
Europe our Jewish friends and family in
Europe Envy us for
it I remember Europe was like it like
that with all the
support in all
areas I remember Europe was quite like
that during The Six Day War and the yur
war but that is all gone now and that
started with the
universities
by the time I went to college in
Amsterdam in the late 70s universities
had become bullworks of Marxism infusing
us with white guilt over our Colonial
past and filling us with rage about the
last Colonial regime Still Standing
Israel arot was glorified as a freedom
fighter in the '90s every journalist in
Europe had gone through this kind of
education and as a result the European
media turned anti-israel and often used
classic anti-semitic accusations like a
nation of child
Killers after the media turned the
population turned a poll in the
Netherlands last week showed that only
25% of the Dutch population is backing
Israel in the current
War many agree that Israel should stop
the child
killing if we don't stop the anti-
israelism the anti-Semitism in America's
universities now the majority of
Americans will turn anti-israel
anti-zionist and anti-semitic a
generation from
now I have the honor to further further
discuss all this with our two
distinguished panelists I will first
introduce the panelist that is new to
this audience
Nale was born in the former Soviet Union
and came to the United States with her
family in
1989 she holds a PhD in Russian
literature from UCLA she has done
research and spoke about Soviet
literature and film at Club Z she
directed the education of Zionism and
Jewish Pride for Jewish youth Nia is a
research fellow at The Institute for the
study of global anti-semitism M or isgap
where she is analyzing current
anti-Semitism and is developing methods
for teaching youth on
anti-Semitism in addition Nia is the
educator editor for White Rose magazine
a magazine about extremism and re
teaching Classical liberalism and she
has a monthly column in the Jerusalem
Post our other panelist hardly needs to
be introduced to this audience our
Robert Spencer is the director of jihad
watch and the schilman fellow at the
David Horwitz Freedom Center he is the
author of 27 books including the history
of
jihad from Muhammad to Isis the critical
Quran explained from Key Islamic
commentaries and contemporary historical
research and the Suter Gambit how the
left is trying to ferment the Civil War
Robert has led seminars on Islam and
Jihad for the FBI the United Central
Command and other National Security and
counterterrorism Departments of the
United States government Robert is also
a senior fellow fellow with the center
for security policy ni and Roberts
welcome and thank you for coming on this
panel thank
you um Nia I'll start with question for
you
so the glorification and joy at American
universities about Hamas horrendous
attack is so incomprehensible to
us that many of the nation's brightest
students professors and University
leaders cannot see the
inhumanity of what happened in Israel
and hail it as the beginning of a better
world allowing campus to become unsafe
for Jews as well we so incomprehensible
to us you you have experience and
expertise in educating young people
about
anti-Semitism can you give us some
insight into the Twisted minds of these
students and their professors and
University leaders what are they
thinking and where did this come
from okay can you all hear me yes all
right so thank you very much for having
me today uh I want to begin by tracing
just the last week and a half to two
weeks in the United States of America in
Tain University here Jewish students
were harassed and accosted and an Israel
flag was burnt about a day ago this is
on social
media uh about a week and a half ago a
former student of mine who's a freshman
at UC Berkeley called me in a panic he
was harassed and he was actually
attacked he was walking across campus
wearing a kipa and an Israel flag and
they came up to him and they started to
tear the kipa and the Israel flag away
from him he said to me but Nia you'd be
very proud I didn't let go of the Israel
flag um in Cornell University we have a
professor Russell rickford who said it
was
exhilarating exhilarating the
brutalization of women and children at
Cooper Union College in New York
students were barricaded I mean in the
United States of America in 2023 Jewish
students are barricaded in a library
because know they feel that
unsafe a Jewish student was beaten with
a stick at Columbia University 2 weeks
ago this is just two
weeks and I realize this isn't a
conference per se about anti-Semitism
but this I'm going to begin with
anti-Semitism is a is an alarm
system where there is
anti-Semitism there is a much bigger
threat to civilization Israel is
fighting on the front lines for the rest
of the world right now because this
isn't just about Israel this is about
attacking Freedom Western Civilization
so I just wanted to start with that but
I do want to answer your question in
order to answer your question how is it
that we have professors who are
screaming it was
exhilarating how is it that we have
multiple departments most of them in
Humanities who sign on to the BDS
campaign who equate Israel with the Nazi
State uh Robert Spencer is going to
speak about more about the uh Islamic
influence I'd like to speak about the
Marxist influence about the Soviet Union
indeed I was born in the former Soviet
Union but I arrived here when I was 6
years old and much of the stories that I
learned about what is anti-zionism I
learned from my parents and I want
everyone here to understand American
Jews are not the first so to speak
victims of anti-zionism these were the
Soviet Jews we they my parents exp that
generation experienced it
first the Soviet Union is a very
interesting um Empire if you will to
study in this particular case in
1948 Stalin voted yes in the UN part uh
partition for the state of Israel and
but we won't go into the history I don't
have too much time but by 1967 there's a
ginormous shift in the Soviet Union in
the sense that you have 1948 approval
sanctioning of a Jewish State because
Stalin thought this would be you know a
small Soviet state an outpost in the
Middle East uh for the Soviet Union but
it didn't go that way and when Israel
actually turned towards the West rather
than towards the Soviet Union the
Soviets turned very much against Israel
we can argue here whether they were
informed or shaped by anti-Semitism but
what they produced is an anti-zionist
campaign a very very well fabricated
campaign language such as Zionism is
racism was not born in the University
hallways in the United States of America
it was born the Soviet
Union um equating Israel to an apartheid
state not born in America or Europe it
was born in the Soviet Union so the
Soviets created this amazing um
anti-zionist machine if you will and
with it they also shipped a certain
narrative framework and we've talked
I've been uh to a few talks today and he
about this framework that is obsessed
with
power that we look at the world through
a lens of Oppression and oppressed you
can also thank the Soviet Union Marxism
for that framework and if you are going
to look at the world and judge State
actors based on such framework if you
were an alien and descended in and
looked at Israel you would most likely
think that Israel is the oppressor
because Israel has power I mean if you
know nothing no context Israel has an
army the Arab Palestinian Arabs do not
Israel has sovereignty they do not
Israel has a state they do not right
they're the quintessential Underdog and
so in such a framework the underdog
because of Marxism everything is about
Powers power structures that's how you
analyze the world for for Marxism it was
about class and class Consciousness
United States of America we are dealing
with race Consciousness and gender
Consciousness but that's for another day
when it comes to Israel and when it
comes to how is it that these professors
all of a sudden find themselves calling
Hamas exhilarating and butchering of
women and children exhilarating because
our students are on the front lines and
they're hearing violence is Justified
when a people is occupied right so if if
if you're looking at that lens you know
oppression leads to violence that's just
not true look at the Jewish experience I
talk to my Jewish students all the time
the Jewish people were kicked out of the
land of Israel 2,000 plus years ago okay
you can say I could with confidence that
Jewish history is a history of
Oppression Jews were oppressed in
Eastern Europe Jews were oppressed in
Arab lands living as deis not they did
not seek violence they did not go rape
butcher children women
elderly so this this entire framework
the only way we will get to this later
but the only way to really deal with the
problem it's not the problem of
anti-Semitism the problem is the
framework itself which breeds and primes
one to become anti-semitic so I just
wanted to to to explain so in terms of
the Soviet Union the Soviets in
1967 fabricated this um really Behemoth
of a campaign against Israel and against
zionists and
so and they shipped it to the West they
shipped it to the Arab world we heard
from Melanie Phillips early where she
discussed how the uh Soviets um
basically gave the uh the Palestinians
their national uh Palestinian narrative
um yaser Arafat would be coming all the
time to to Moscow to the KGB Mahmud
Abbas who's the Palestinian Authority
leader wrote his dissertation in Moscow
State University effectively denying the
Holocaust um so what we have we're
picking up the remnants of the Soviet
system my mother who's not a historian
but she's a very wise woman she says you
know Nia the Soviets may have lost the
Cold War but they won the ideological
war and and and I think she's right I
think seeing what we're seeing in on our
campuses and it's not even campuses
anymore it's k through eight it's in
it's in high schools where if you look
at the world through such a framework
where oppression is just everything you
do if you're oppressed you're therefore
Justified and if you're the oppressor
well you're inherently evil uh that is
why effectively I believe that we've
they've lost their minds they've lost
their moral compass they've lost the
ability to see clearly because they've
boughten into this into this narrative
and our job is not necessarily fighting
the anti-Semitism it's fighting The
Narrative which breeds the
anti-Semitism thank you what how did
they manage to to reach almost all of
the school system all of the college
system how did they manage yeah um
well it's it's a longer conversation
about Academia and what happened in
1960s in in in Academia and why for
instance the Frankfurt School from
Germany came to dominate um they were
the
neo-marxists it really comes back to to
Marxist um ideology so I studied
literature right I studied Russian
literature and lo and behold in my
Russian literature classes we did
postcolonial analysis of Anna Karenina I
mean why would we be doing postcolonial
analysis of Anna karenin or War and
Peace right so that's Michelle Fuko
right so Michelle Fuko was a is a very
important uh uh philosopher
theoretician lauded lionized by
academics uh because you know if I had
to really answer you I think humans All
Humans seek purpose and if you don't
have God then you're going to create a
different worldview wherein you want
Justice these these are not evil people
they want
to help the persecuted they just have
terrible
remedies but but but to understand how
they won the hearts and minds they have
won the hearts and minds and I want to
just really briefly um just give you a
study so uh the Jewish Institute for
Liberal values in 2022 uh conducted a
study and I just want to show you
something very interesting and you think
what you may of these results so for de
they compared Democrats Republicans and
radical progressives so what do what do
Democrats in America care about what do
Republicans and what do progressives so
the top five for Democrats are inflation
economy climate change coid and crime
okay for for
Republicans top five is inflation
immigration border economy crime and
National Security and for the radical
progressives the top top five are
Universal Health Care climate change
structural racism economy jobs inflation
so and what the study actually found is
a high correlation people who hold
radically Progressive views end
up being
anti-israel it's I I I want to stress
this really it's very important in the
work that I do it's not that these
people are inherently they come with an
anti-semitic bias but that but looking
at the world where you care about
universal healthcare climate change
structural racism inflation economy and
you apply the lens of power and
powerlessness you are going to end up
being against the state of
Israel so the battle is a de it's a deep
battle it's it's a long battle
anti-Semitism is just the alarm it's the
alarm that something is rotten in
Denmark thank
you
Robert um we often hear this Narrative
of Oppression and victimhood of the
Palestinians and their lack of
self-determination as the cause of
hamas's brutal attack and as the root of
the Israeli Palestinian conflict what do
you think of that
narrative the whole idea of situating
this conflict in the language of
Oppression is just what Nia was saying
to justify any action against the
oppressor and this is actually the most
impressive achievement of the Soviet
propaganda starting from the 1960s the
creation of the Palestinian people
themselves who were never in existence
before the
1960s uh you can look at all the
literature all the Contemporary
newspapers all the UN discussions
everything regarding the creation of the
state of Israel in 1948 and you're not
going to find any mention of the
Palestinians they did not
exist there were Arabs who were
indistinguishable linguistically
culturally religiously from the Arabs of
Syria Jordan and
Lebanon they were created by the KGB and
Yasser Arafat in the 1960s precisely to
be
oppressed there are no Palestinian
people apart from the Marxist language
of Oppression that Nia was discussing
the Palestinian people only exist in
order to situate the to the Jihad
against Israel which is based on Islamic
principles within the Marxist framework
of the struggle of an oppressed people
against its
oppressor and thus that is the source of
the Coalition between the left and Islam
the reason reason why negotiations have
always failed is because of the
maximalism of the Islamic imperative
that is as I explained this morning the
Quran passage drive them out from where
they drove you out that does not admit
of a half solution or a negotiated peace
or anything other than the total
eradication of the state of Israel now
how do you get leftists on board with
that is say these are an oppressed
people who need to be liberated
from their oppressor so the PLO start
and the pflp the popular front from the
for the liberation of Palestine they
were Marxist organizations that became
progressively more Islamic as time went
on the pflp is still essentially a
Marxist organization but it's a minority
among the Islamic groups among the
Palestinian groups the Islamic aspect of
this actually came second it second to
the Marxist part but they were able to
capitalize upon this aspect of Islamic
doctrine that will not allow a
non-muslim state on territory that Islam
once once or ever
ruled and this creates this terrible
Alliance that
has cons persisted all this time and
that we see bearing this bitter fruit
today with so many non
Muslim non-palestinian college students
all over as Nia said thinking their
cause is righteous when they engage in
this brutal and bloody Behavior or
justify
it thank you
um Nia how this is
a a difficult topic um for for many of
us but I think we have to ask the
question to start to understand it and
then hopefully resolve it
how come there are even Jewish students
and professors um going along with the
glorification of what Hamas did two
weeks
ago it's very painful to talk about this
and and it's shameful um I'm going to
speak about the failure of Jewish
Education if you ask these people that
Robert Spencer just said who are
fighting for a quote unquote righteous
cause are do you do you not like Jews
are you anti-semitic they would say
absolutely not and they've been
it who do they don't dislike zionists we
don't have a problem with Jews we have a
problem with zionists but that's not on
them that's on us that's on us Jewish
Americans that we haven't educated our
Jewish children to understand that is to
be a Jew is to be a Zionist it's one and
the same my mother told me again from
the Soviet Union right before uh we IM
immigrated and of course she lost her
job uh one of the co-workers came to her
and said all along you've been making
this into a Zionist Nest you've been
transforming this job this workplace
into a Zionist nest and of course the
left is brilliant brilliant with
language the Soviets were brilliant they
didn't say Jewish Nest they said Zionist
nest because they couldn't be outwardly
anti-semitic so again they played that
really really well the anti-zionism mask
and so so so it's a big failure a big
huge failure on Jewish institutions and
Legacy organizations who have again I'm
going to say that word again failed to
teach that Judaism is not just a
religion it's an ethnicity we are a
people from a land of Israel number one
number two I also think that it's
nothing new or radical that Jews are
anti-jewish this is not new in Jewish
history uh again I you know my my area
is Soviet Union when the Soviets had
just taken over from the uh red uh from
the whites um the white being the
Vanguard of the of the tarist they set
up many unions in many different
sections one of them was called y or the
Jewish section of the Soviet police what
you know what they did you know what
their whole entire retra was their
entire goal name they had to go to the
pale of settlements where Jews once
lived and
basically
humiliate cut off beards of fellow
rabbis in order to say you have to
become a Soviet you have to jettison
your
Jewish backwardness or Jewish
religion we could have been sitting and
having this panel in 1919 how could
there be Jews running around in the
Soviet Union cutting off beards and
desecrating holy you know sedur holy
texts to to fill out um sorry prayers
prayers excuse me so again it's not
new right it's not a new phenomenon
anti-jew who are Jews who are against
Jews but the only way I can rationalize
it the only way I can understand it in
terms of the American context is that
America in terms of the Jewish
establishment and education massively
failed uh in teaching their children
what it means to be a Jew that if you
are a Jew you are a Zionist they're
synonyms okay thank
you um Robert since we talk about campus
and the hearts and minds of young people
can you give us um a very brief overview
of how the radical left and islamism
have come to dominate our
campuses yes certainly uh but just one
note on
Nia's observations there and that is
that uh there are many Jews of course
who are leftists as we all know but
leftism because it's inherently
collectivist is anti-jewish and this is
why it always ends up in
anti-Semitism and you have Stalin was uh
going to persecute the Jews right before
he died and Hitler who was essentially
man of the left in his core principles
persecuted the Jews and so many others
this is because of the kind of thing
that Nia mentioned about the the Jews
going to various places and saying you
have to cut your beards to their fellow
Jews the whole idea of the collective is
uniformity and everybody's the same and
the Jews as the people who've had no
home for 2,000 years and were in every
other culture in every other
civilization and never gave up their
individuality they are a standing rebuke
to the core idea of the
left and so it's a fundamental
contradiction for Jews to be leftists
but I think they haven't really thought
leftism through well enough uh in any
case the
campus aspect of this proceeded along
the lines of that same Marxism now we
could have a whole discussion about how
the marxists took over the universities
and that's another story but we know
that they did and the Long March through
the instit institutions is well known uh
and it was capitalized upon very
cleverly by the forces of jihad and the
Islamic uh action against Israel one
primary example of that is students for
justice in Palestine which is a very
extensive uh group on 200 campuses
around the country it's essentially a
gang of thugs that menaces Jewish and
pro-israeli students on a regular basis
if they do anything too publicly in
support of the state of Israel the
students for justice in Palestine was
founded at University of California
Berkley in 2001 by a professor named
hatm bazian who is still there and he's
a professor of
islamophobia uh which is of course a
madeup word that's designed to
intimidate people people into thinking
that there's something wrong with
resisting Jihad violence and the
oppression of women and others that is
Justified in Sharia so hatm bazian is a
very interesting case he is not only the
founder of students for justice in
Palestine he's a Palestinian Arab
himself from nablo he is a migrant to
the United States and uh he very
skillfully from an an early age began
to spearhead the identification of the
Palestinian Jihad with the left's core
ideals for example he uh was at one
point while he was a student the leader
of a group called The National people of
color student
Coalition now if you've ever seen a
picture of hatm bazian he's a white
guy and the Arabs have always been
classified as white in the US
Census and the whole idea that Arabs are
people of color I think the absurdity of
this is well summed up by hatm bazan's
friend and colleague Linda
sarur who has faded from public view but
she was quite prominent a few years back
the hijab wearing far-left activist part
of the women's movement and so on you
can find a video still there on YouTube
of L sarur saying that uh before she put
decided to wear hijab she was just an
ordinary white
girl and then you can also find Linda
sarur in numerous contexts saying she is
a person of color or brown so the very
very putting on the hijab changed her
race and that's a remarkable thing but
the whole idea is here again to situate
the Jihad against Israel
in the struggle of the oppressed people
against the oppressor that the left is
is supposed to be all about and hatm
bazian is a tremendous example of the
success of this as a professor at one of
the leading most far-left universities
in the country a professor of a concept
that the left made up in order to demean
and silence its critics and he has
openly he openly called like over 20
years years ago for inata in the United
States and nobody seemed to care of
course because people who believe the
same way as he does are ensconsed in all
the positions of power that might have
called him to account and so now we are
bearing we are seeing the fruits of
seeds that have been planted decades
ago and Robert um is is there um is is
the the founder of students for justice
in Palestine hat and basan is he
affiliated with Hamas yes uh he's pretty
much an open supporter of it but he was
when he was also student he was in the
Muslim Students Association and the
Muslim Students Association is the
primary Muslim Brotherhood organization
in the United States that has been
explicitly tied to the Muslim
Brotherhood uh even in the secular media
which ordinarily ignor all this
altogether there was a big expose in the
Chicago Tribune in 2004 where the Muslim
Students Association was identified as
the Muslim brotherhood's Chief arm in
the United States now in order to
understand the significance of that look
at the Hamas Charter and in the Hamas
Charter it says the Hamas organization
which by the way as you know probably is
an acronym for Islamic resistance
movement the Islamic resistance move
movement is the Muslim Brotherhood
branch in Palestine and the Muslim
Brotherhood according to a captured
internal document that was discovered
some years back it is dedicated in its
own words to eliminating and destroying
Western Civilization from within and
sabotaging its miserable house by their
hands that is the hands of the
westerners they're going to kill
themselves by their hands and the hands
of the Believers so that it falls and
Allah's religion religion is Victorious
over other religions that's a quote from
the Quran which speaks about how the
enemies of Allah began to uh defeat
themselves by their own hands that is
they they they turned against each other
and began to fight and that is one of
the core ideas of the Muslim Brotherhood
that they will seow division in the
United States so that ultimately the
United States will fall and you can see
it's working great
I think it's 200 branches the students
of Jud the students for justice in
Palestine have in America and they are
organizing most of these Ries on campus
and intimidations of other students
Jewish students and
others um so we basically have 200
branches of the Muslim Brotherhood in
American campuses
um my question to both of you and then
I'll open it up for the audience who
must be burning with uh with
questions how can we
reverse the anti-semitic brainwashing of
students in America
NAA there
are two schools of thought one is change
current institutions and the second
build your own I'm of the mindset that
we've lost the institutions we must
build our own
own what do I mean by that I mean if you
are waiting until College it's too late
we have to start winning back the hearts
and minds of our children and that means
classical education and I think Chris
Chris rufo spoke of a curriculum that he
is uh part of where they're trying to
basically but they're working with the
state of Florida of course they're
working with someone who is is open to
it but the point is is there are tons of
classically educated children who are
going to classical education schools
most of them of course are Christian
Schools I think Jew there needs to be a
burgeoning of Jewish schools Jewish Day
schools that are teaching Western values
pro-american
values God morality because it's not
happening in in in schools and one thing
I'll tell you something else I used to
live in California as well in California
during the height of Co
most parents started to pull their
children out of schools because they had
a front R seat through Zoom of what was
happening in their children's classrooms
once again this isn't just about the
anti-Semitism the anti-Semitism is
signaling the other rot and and what
they saw and what I saw because I Al at
that time my son was in second or third
grade what we saw was they had
assemblies on Zoom pledging for BLM they
were taking time out of the classroom to
pledge for BLM M right teachers had
their gender pronouns and told students
to also use gender pronouns and so what
ended up happening there was a massive
wave of parents pulling their kids out
uh so we need to start a network a
movement so we need to start our own
institutions what else prageru prageru
is a wonderful Source uh they've just uh
not just it's a couple years now they've
invested in uh basically creating a
Prager you kids version of what they
have for adults they're growing that
educating children um through YouTube uh
with a their own YouTube channel um but
I I I do not believe that we can change
the current institutions and one more
thing I'd like to just say how dire the
situation is so that study that I
referenced the the study that was
conducted in
2022 they found that amongst no surprise
amongst the boomer generation we have
52% in favor of Israel within one
generation Millennials it drops to 31 I
don't even know what the they didn't
study the Gen Z you can imagine what the
Gen Z and that and and and the
interesting thing about this particular
study and I can definitely share the
results with with with you all through
the administrators here is that the
people who were conducting this survey
were not necessarily interested let's
say in who holds anti-semitic or
anti-zionist or anti-israel views they
were interested in seeing people who
hold those views tend to vote Which Way
tend to believe what about climate
Justice tend to believe what about
reproductive Justice and there's a huge
correlation
so this is about getting our kids and
the only way to get our kids back is we
have to build our own schools we have to
build our own Community
programs that's what I believe
personally I really do and and classical
education ation thank you and University
of Austin Texas is also an example of a
new University that wants to bring
classical
education um Robert what what do you
think
um how can we reverse how can we reverse
this this brainwashing burn the
universities down and sew the ground
with
salt
uh
I just want to say hello to my friends
in the NSA no it was just a little
quip um in any case the universities are
in a terrible State and people don't
realize the general public has no idea
what propaganda factories they've become
I was talking to this guy a few years
ago and he was down the line he would
have fit right in here he agreed with
the point of view that all the speakers
have espoused during this weekend on all
the various issues
and then he said that he was going to
give a million dollars to his alma mater
which was one of the leading leftist
universities in the country and I I I I
I didn't want to be rude but I thought I
wanted to say what are you nuts the
universities are standing against
everything that we are trying to achieve
everything we're trying to defend and
protect and so they have to be
thoroughly repudiated we should see
movements that want to deny them all
funding that is based on taxpayer money
in whatever way and every last support
yes that they have from the state needs
to be removed and then if the if if
George Soros wants to fund them that's
his business but at least it will be
clear that these are you institutions
with a particular point of view and not
neutral learnings then nobody should be
fooled may may I just add to that it in
addition to what Robert just said which
is that our universities are basically
financially owned by Qatar um and so
that you know we can pull all the
funding out you could pull your $100,000
donation $1 million it stands nothing
against the 20 million that they throw
they you know I I was at a conference
this summer in Oxford somebody did a
brief and and showed us the map of the
world and basically the chips that have
been laid out by Qatar Qatar owns 33% of
the Empire State
Building Qatar owns 67% of he airport
why what about Georgetown University
Colombia
NYU we we cannot send our kids to
college I'm not sending my son to
college absolutely I'm sorry but I I
can't resist why do they own 33% of the
Empire State Building and he throw
airport well they have to have a place
for the plane to take off to crash into
the sorry sorry but Roberts do you see a
way to get rid of the Qatari uh
financing of America's universities
that's an excellent question that's a
larger question than just cutter as well
because you have the Chinese money you
have Saudi money which actually is older
and is waning now with the Saudi Crown
Prince trying to change course but the
the the damage is done to a tremendous
degree it would be interesting to see if
uh you could get any interest in
Congress for some sort of a measure to
prohibit foreign funding of American
universities that would change the
cultural landscape radically overnight
probably to the extent that all the
politicians who've been bought by cutter
and Saudi Arabia and the rest would
oppose it
vociferously thank you um I want to give
uh the the opportunity to the audience
to ask questions Evelyn I'm right over
here so we've got time for a couple of
questions I have one quick correction
James O'Keefe at 4:15 is not in this
room but back where we had lunch so just
so you know at 4:15 but we've got about
15 minutes or 10 or 15 minutes so we'll
take a few questions the first one is
right here hello thank you these are uh
complicated issues and you know when you
study mathematics you try to go
fundamental what are the fundamental
things and it seems like the things that
permeate the fertilizer is destruction
of family destruction of any concept of
a higher being and no matter what it
comes down to that you destroy a family
you destroy a concept of many higher
being you always uh able to get a
homogeneous population and they rely on
the
[Music]
state I I I you know it's interesting
what you just said is very interesting
in terms of Islam but in terms of the
Soviet Union the Soviet Union did
exactly that uh they replaced the family
unit they sewed into civilization
distrust you know Stalin was paranoid uh
so basically it wasn't just that your
friends or colleagues could snitch on
you your own family members and we have
a case in the Soviet Union of a boy
named okay sorry for my pavic marov okay
very Russian name the story of pavic Mor
roev is that he ratted his father out
because of father was a kulok which is a
rich peasant and they came and they took
his father away they murdered his
dad um and he became a hero so think
about for just for one second who
becomes a hero in the Soviet Union
somebody whose loyalty is first and
foremost to the to to to ID to the
ideology not to the family which is
interesting because I'm not sure how it
is with
Islam I think Islam has a very strong uh
value on family unit so it' be that
would be an interesting kind of question
well actually the Quran repeatedly says
that even if your father or your mother
or your brother is an unbeliever then
you have to fight against him that uh
you should hate there should be
Everlasting enmity as a matter of fact
it's interesting point this comes in the
context of a passage about Abraham and
you hear a lot about the abrahamic
faiths and how Judaism Christianity and
Islam are all children of Abraham and
how wonderful that is and it's a basis
for Unity it's a lot of hogwash because
what the Quran actually says about
Abraham is that he was not a Jew or a
Christian he was a Muslim and he says to
his father who was an unbeliever that
there will be enmity and hatred between
us and You Forever Until You Believe in
Allah so he's talking to his own father
and he says I'm going to hate you
forever because you're not a Muslim and
he's held up in that specific instance
as an excellent example for imitation by
the
Muslims got a question over
here so focusing on Solutions you know
anti-Semitism been a around a long
time Crusades weren't so great for the
Jews either so it's it's been been a
problem so two ideas maybe we should get
behind number one go ahead and revoke
the 501c3 status for all of these
so-called
universities that are allowing Jews to
be persecuted number two I love what you
said great our own institutions what
we'll do that in Spades is if we get the
states to get the money to follow the
student and
defund these lousy public
schools I agree with you anti-Semitism
is the as they say Robert worrich said
is the oldest hatred it is the oldest
hatred so on that I agree and and I'm a
big believer um in in in in my dream in
one day I will have a school I will
found my own school and the school will
teach the right
values okay we're going to go Judy and
then I think Jay had a question for
okay you may want to bring me up to date
but as far as I know the zoa actually
put forward a
um um a legal whatever that the
government not fund any um
any uh American funded schools any
non-for-profit American funded schools
if they are um involved in anti-Semitism
and things like that and I think it was
during the Trump
Administration but uh I don't remember
what the particular thing is but I know
that the zoa went after them so we need
more of
that the the Zionist organization of
America
zoa J you have a question yeah okay real
quick um when you mentioned the qari
money and the Saudi money all coming in
is that state sponsored money or is that
private individuals or or organizations
that are donating it's generally private
individuals but the private individuals
are semi-private I mean you've got
somebody like aled bin tal and he is a
Saudi Prince he has poured tens of
millions if not hundreds of millions of
dollars into American
universities uh as well as other
organizations and institutions in the
United States and he was actually
briefly imprisoned by Muhammad bin
Salman the Crown Prince a few years back
it appeared that he was part of a more
Hardline Islamic faction that was
objecting to what MBS was trying to do
in relaxing a lot of the uh Sharia
requirements so he was clearly tied into
the previous Saudi regime which you
can't you can't tell the Saudi regimes
by The King The King was the same all
the way through but who were the people
really in charge but the ostensibly the
money was a donation from this guy who
just happened to be fantastically
wealthy next question right here yeah hi
thank you for your uh informative talk
uh are you heartened to see some of the
push back that's coming from leading law
firms in the United States who are
revoking uh job offers to students who
have been involved in these on campus um
protests and also uh
they've I've seen other major business
people saying they won't hire people
from these
universities I'm surprised I didn't see
this before but it's starting to happen
and what do you think of that
Trend na I'm not quite aware of that
Trend as but I think it's a wonderful
Trend uh but I'm not quite aware of it
so I cannot speak you Robert yeah there
are uh it's it's very good to see that
as as you noted there are several law
firms and other organizations that have
said that people who are identified and
they're open about their identities and
of course the video is everywhere
nowadays because everybody's got a phone
and so people who are identified at
these pramas rallies have lost job
offers have had job offers rescinded H
there have been announcements that
nobody will be hired from this
University or that University uh there
has been I I don't want to be glass half
empty guy but there have been very few
of these it's heartening to see them to
be sure uh you would expect there to be
more I think it it's it's more shocking
that there has been such open support
and gleeful expression of joy as as Nia
noted about the massacre on October 7th
and that that people seem to think
they're not going to suffer any
consequences for this and for the most
part they
won't so maybe when I listen to this
great
conversation um Jews are not only the
canary and the coal mine but may also
become the spearhead of fighting back
against an ideology that affects all our
freedom what can our audience
do to fight back against this ideology
that is bad for Jews in universities bad
for Jews and bad for
everybody Nia okay you know evely and I
were speaking earlier about this you
know it's interesting everybody wants a
solution to your point you um you you
asked what's the solution and and I
can't help invoke my own background
which is a liter literary scholar you
know if we look at the Arc of
Storytelling rising action tension
resolution I mean everybody we just want
a resolution and an easy one one
um the I heard we're in trouble uh we
are in trouble but but the fact is that
you are here and and and are you know
becoming more and more aware of this
topic pull your funding out I mean yeah
you probably don't stand much Against
guitar but you know Jewish
philanthropists must pull their funding
from universities I don't understand why
um uh Mr louder is still funding
University of Pennsylvania I really
don't quite understand that
um well he he he he he uh he said that
he would take he would if if action
wasn't if there was no action he would
resend his his his you know
Hefty gift if you will but I haven't
seen
it again I believe in build you you want
to save this country I want to to I came
from the former Soviet Union I don't I I
love the United States of America my
parents love this country this country
is freedom but if you want to save it
you have let's build our own
institutions what did Turning Point USA
do Turning Point USA is is is a
leadership program for youth they didn't
say oh let's try to work within the
youth programs no they made they made
their own that's what we need to do we
need to make our own schools our own
universities and just and be done with
them
and Robert what's going become
obnoxious okay what I mean is very
quickly sorry the people here there's
half the seats empty and I love you all
but I see you every year where are the
new people have you been going out and
telling people about how dire the
situation is most of the people going
about their business have no idea and
they might be receptive if you show them
some of the videos from the campuses or
some of the things that have been coming
out lately
they might actually be moved to act and
we need to grow our
numbers that's all okay if we can do
this uh fast we're going to get to go
from Frank uh up to Bernie if we can do
two questions we'll see if this I hope
this is a quick answer U Robert we
talked a little bit this morning about
the president of the United States
meeting with Muslim Brotherhood
operatives could you just talk quickly
about the penetration of our government
by these guys in key positions in
particular in the contribution it's
making to policies more generally but
specifically on the anti-Semitism issue
do you know that the chief negotiator
that the Biden regime has for the
Israeli Palestinian issue is a
Palestinian pro- Jihad activist named
hadamar and there are other high up in
the Biden regime other people who are
Palestinian jihadis essentially you you
can be a Jihadi without blowing things
up if you are aiding the Jihad and and
uh this is the fruit of his promise as
Frank noted that Biden would appoint
Muslims at every level of the US
government that was the Brotherhood that
he was talking to M Gage is a
Brotherhood organization and the
Brotherhood as I noted before is
dedicated to eliminating and destroying
Western Civilization from within but
they have very can also situated
themselves at the in the corridors of
power and this has been going on for
years and years years like 2002 2005 you
had Muslims hired to show that these
various agencies weren't islamophobic
and then they would target the people
who were strongest and complain and get
them fired like Colonel Steven coglin
and so on in the Pentagon and then they
would bring in their own people and now
that's Advanced by nearly 20 years and
we're seeing once again the fruit of it
okay this will be the last question this
is going to be a quick rhetorical
question to the audience how many of you
are aware that if there is a bureau in
the US Department of Education that
accepts complaints validated for
anti-Semitism on any title six granted
organization if you have evidence of
anti-Semitism genocide whatever how many
are aware of that in this room if you're
complaining about your University or
whatever you can file a complaint with
the evidence they go to that University
they give them a cure period better yet
they'll tell you to contact that
University and tell them your about to
file a complaint it has results it took
down Northwestern University recently
when they censored SJP thank
you any any comment up from the the
group on that um I'm sir I've been
involved with several title six and
unfortunately most of them never ever
make it to try never ever make it and
the only one that I'm aware of was uh
Adela cohab who was able to
re basically win in Columbia University
but that is only because president Trump
had included under the definition for
title 6 he included ethnicity as also
part of the protected classes title 6 is
is a very complicated very complicated
um you know thing B it's a it's you can
file it they're not terrified of it most
of them don't
win just just to be clear they didn't
actually file they told Northwestern
they were going to file and the next day
Northwestern University forced SJP to
take down
all okay that's great that's amazing I
mean also told them they thrown off
campus that's did that again amazing I'm
but most of the time that you know USC
Rose Rich a student was basically forced
to leave campus she was afraid for her
life she went to the brandise uh Legal
Center and they basically tried to file
a six and it didn't
work but but I'm yeah it is it is a
recourse it is
there and I'm really glad that it you
know it it it had some sort of tangible
effect in was it Northeastern Northwest
Northwestern we can use and it isn't
always to work we have to fight y okay I
want to thank Evelyn Marcus and a
wonderful panel
and